hey this is Leon British and this is a
song called River
been traveling these wide roads so long
my heart's been for you around the time
and I wrote it I was really down really
depressed because you know I was working
like a whole bunch of jobs to help
support my mom and myself and I felt
like I was in a hole and I had this
vision to play music and in wanting to
do that for a living but I always felt
that that could never happen in my
darkness I remember Mama's words we
occur to me surrender to the good Lord
you know wipe your sake it all started
in Fort Worth Texas me playing every
Tuesday night at a bar this guy he walks
in he came up to me after I got done
with my gig it was like are those covers
and I was like nah they're my songs and
he was like whoa they sound great let's
record him that was the beginning of
everything who I want to come me
if it reported me put this blood on my
hand
I've been hateful towards people you
know I've been I've lied you know I
haven't been a perfect person it's just
about like the wrong that I'm you know
that I live you know and all kind of
things that doesn't measure up with the
spiritual way of living take me to your
River I wanna go the idea of being
baptized in a river um has been used I
mean in gospel music so many times and
it shows that I'm not perfect
but the Lord doesn't care like well you
know what's the wrong the wrong that
I've done and so that's what rivers
about take me to your River High